Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Circa 10.000 anni fa,
l'uomo ha inventato l'agricoltura.
Ha addomesticato piante e animali
in determinate aree del mondo,
e la Mezzaluna Fertile è stata
una dei punti più importanti
di domesticazione
di piante - abbiamo sentito, il frumento -
e di molte specie animali.
Piante e animali, domesticati,
hanno poi colonizzato il mondo,
seguendo l'espansione dell'agricoltura
e altre vicende umane:
conquiste, migrazioni.
E si sono spostate in zone
con degli ambienti agro-climatici
molto diversi dal sito di domesticazione.
La selezione naturale, in millenni,
ha reso questi animali adatti, quindi,
a vivere in condizioni molto diverse:
a climi estremi,
patogeni diversi, terreni diversi,
alimentazioni a disposizione diverse.
E questo ha creato l'adattamento
degli animali, e delle piante,
a produrre in condizioni diverse.
Un esempio: questa capra in Marocco -
una capra addomesticata
sui monti del Taurus, in Anatolia -
si è adattata a vivere in ambienti
molto più caldi, in Marocco,
e a cibarsi, quando non c'è
vegetazione sul terreno,
dei frutti di un albero,
l'albero dell'argan.
Tra parentesi, contribuisce poi
a disseminare i semi di questa pianta.
Queste soluzioni genetiche,
che la selezione naturale
ha trovato in millenni,
sono contenute in razze locali.
Ma queste razze locali, purtroppo,
sono a rischio di estinzione,
si stanno perdendo.
La FAO, nel 2015, ha stimato
che circa un terzo di tutte le risorse
genetiche e animali del pianeta,
di animali zootecnici,
sono a rischio di estinzione.
E di un terzo non se ne sa nulla.
E queste sono una preziosa
fonte di adattamento
per l'agricoltura in generale.
Alla selezione naturale si è integrata,
dalla domesticazione in avanti,
la selezione dell'uomo.
Prima per gli animali,
per il comportamento;
ma in seguito proprio
per l'efficienza produttiva.
Dopo la Rivoluzione Industriale,
la capacità dell'uomo di selezionare,
di scegliere i genotipi migliori
è aumentata notevolmente,
grazie alla crescita, anche,
di approcci di tipo scientifico.
E progressivamente, questo ha portato
a quella che conosciamo oggi
come agricoltura intensiva:
allevamenti intensivi
e agricoltura, piante,
coltivate in modo industriale.
Queste da un lato hanno
un grande impatto ambientale, lo sappiamo:
utilizzano energia, arature profonde,
pesticidi, fertilizzanti,
farmaci in azienda,
grande densità di allevamenti
che se non ben condotti possono, anche,
dare problemi di benessere animale;
d'altra parte, hanno permesso
di moltiplicare le produzioni -
per esempio per quattro
la produzione di latte
e addirittura per dieci
la produzione del mais -
in un secolo.
E hanno risposto
a delle dinamiche sociali:
dopo la Rivoluzione Industriale,
la popolazione
è cresciuta esponenzialmente,
si è radunata nelle città
lasciando le campagne
e ha chiesto cibo sempre più abbondante,
sicuro e a un prezzo basso.
E il risultato, la risposta,
è stata l'agricoltura industriale.
Un secondo passo in avanti
sulla produttività è molto recente,
grazie all'era, alla rivoluzione del DNA.
Negli ultimi 10 - 12 anni, 20 anni,
siamo riusciti ad aumentare
la velocità di lettura del DNA,
quindi del codice genetico
di piante, animali e dell'uomo,
in una maniera esponenziale:
pensate che, se nel 1980
la velocità poteva essere paragonata
a quella di una lumaca
che si muove a un metro all'ora,
quindi una lumaca anche abbastanza lenta,
quella di oggi può essere paragonata
a un jet supersonico
che vola a molte migliaia
di chilometri all'ora.
In modo analogo, è diminuito
il costo delle analisi del DNA:
un miliardo di dollari nel 2001,
per sequenziare il primo genoma umano;
meno di 1.000 dollari adesso.
E questo ci ha permesso
di aumentare moltissimo
il livello di risoluzione
con cui noi riusciamo
ad analizzare il DNA,
e quindi anche a comprenderne la biologia.
Per fare un paragone, possiamo dire
che siamo passati da un basso -
molti pochi pixel, come vedete,
qui in questo quadro si può pensare
di intravedere Monna Lisa -
a una risoluzione molto maggiore.
E questo ci ha permesso anche di capire
quando prendevamo degli abbagli.
(Risate)
[Livello di risoluzione
nell'analisi del DNA]
E l'analisi del DNA, in realtà,
ci ha permesso di aumentare
l'efficienza della selezione.
Aumentare l'efficienza della selezione -
vi faccio un esempio sul toro da latte.
Il toro da latte non produce latte:
quindi la sua valutazione genetica,
fino a cinque anni fa,
era basata sulla produzione delle figlie.
Ma le figlie, per produrre latte,
dovevano aver partorito.
Per cui, in sintesi,
un toro veniva valutato quando era nonno.
E solo da nonno poteva essere scelto
come grande riproduttore,
quindi il suo seme essere sparso
nella popolazione oppure scartato.
La genomica, quindi l'analisi del DNA,
permette adesso di valutare un toro
non appena nasce.
Non dobbiamo aspettare
le produzioni delle figlie:
sappiamo immediatamente,
guardando il suo DNA,
se il toro sarà un buon riproduttore
oppure se sarà da scartare.
E questo ha accelerato,
e ha moltiplicato per tre,
la velocità di selezione
dei riproduttori in questo settore.
In modo analogo, nelle piante,
le stesse tecnologie
stanno facendo la stessa cosa,
quindi abbiamo aumentato
la nostra velocità.
Ma perché la velocità
è sempre più importante?
È importante perché ci sono
alcune dinamiche in atto
che sono dinamiche rapidissime.
Prima dinamica:
aumento esponenziale della popolazione,
saremo 10 miliardi nel 2050.
La FAO ha stimato
che avremo bisogno del 70 percento in più
di quello che c'è adesso di cibo.
E qui c'è un problema,
perché abbiamo a disposizione,
per l'agricoltura,
un miliardo e mezzo di ettari
su questo pianeta.
Ma non possiamo aumentarli
in modo significativo:
dobbiamo magari utilizzare qualche terra
adesso considerata marginale,
ma sicuramente non dobbiamo deforestare.
Cosa fare?
Una prima cosa da fare
è sicuramente diminuire gli sprechi,
dal campo fino alla tavola
del consumatore.
Ma questo non è sufficiente:
bisogna essere più efficienti
nella produzione di cibo
su questi ettari a disposizione.
Secondo problema:
il riscaldamento globale.
La quantità di CO2 è in continuo aumento,
è in aumento esponenziale
dalla Rivoluzione Industriale
a causa dell'attività umana.
L'agricoltura dà un contributo,
e il contributo -
le stime di questo contributo
variano tantissimo:
se parlate agli agricoltori è bassissima,
se parlate agli industriali è altissima.
Comunque variano dal nove al 25 percento,
con almeno metà
di questo impatto ambientale
dovuto alle produzioni animali.
E in particolare,
le emissioni di metano
da parte dei ruminanti.
E il metano è un gas serra molto potente.
Ma qualunque sia, diciamo,
questo contributo dell'agricoltura
alla produzione di CO2,
questo deve essere sicuramente mitigato:
bisogna ridurre questo impatto.
Aumentando, però, la produttività.
Una bella sfida!
E perché bisogna ridurre
la produzione di CO2?
Perché sta aumentando
la temperatura del pianeta.
Sta aumentando:
gli scienziati della NASA hanno stimato
che sia, circa, aumentata di un grado
negli ultimi 100 anni.
Quindi un aumento molto veloce,
ed è per questo che sottolineavo,
prima, la necessità di andare veloci.
Per chi non crede ai dati della NASA,
ci sono delle prove
circostanziali, molto evidenti,
del riscaldamento del pianeta.
Siamo tutti in attesa del prossimo step.
(Risate)
Quindi, ci sarà una crisi alimentare?
Saremo abbastanza veloci
nel produrre di più inquinando di meno?
Sono due urgenze.
Be', diciamo che la ricerca
sta studiando nuove tecnologie.
Una di queste
si chiama "genome editing",
editare il genoma.
Ed è una nuova tecnologia
che permette, come in un word processor,
di cancellare una lettera del DNA
e sostituirla con un'altra.
In alcuni casi,
la sostituzione o la cancellazione
di una sola lettera
può indurre una modifica sostanziale
in un carattere
di una pianta o di un animale:
in questo caso, per esempio,
la cancellazione di una lettera nel riso
rende il riso resistente a una malattia
che si chiama brusone,
e che di solito viene combattuta
con dei pesticidi
ad alto impatto ambientale.
Questa mutazione è presente
in alcune varietà:
quindi quello che fa l'editing,
essenzialmente,
[è riuscire] a copiare le soluzioni
che sono state trovate
dalla selezione naturale
che sono presenti nelle razze locali
e nelle varietà locali.
Semplicemente, le prende e le copia
all'interno delle varietà più produttive.
La stessa cosa per l'assenza
di corna dei bovini:
esistono, ci sono popolazioni bovine
che non hanno corna.
E l'assenza di corna
è un carattere favorevole
sia per gli uomini, gli operatori
che lavorano in stalla con i bovini,
sia per gli animali stessi
che si possono far male.
E si fanno male per stabilire
delle relazioni di gerarchia.
Anche in questo caso,
la mutazione nelle razze locali
è stata presa, e copiata,
nelle razze più produttive.
Un'altra novità
è che nel topo, l'anno scorso,
hanno differenziato spermatozoi
da cellule staminali.
È abbastanza, per noi maschi,
insomma, un pugno nello stomaco.
Perché?
Ma perché, se noi prendiamo
un embrione femmina,
e differenziamo gli spermatozoi,
nasceranno solo femmine;
e a questo punto il maschio
non sarà più necessario.
Mi sono quindi immedesimato
abbastanza, nei poveri topi.
Comunque, diciamo che mettendo insieme
queste tecnologie, ripensandoci:
la genomica;
le biotecnologie della riproduzione;
l'editing, cioè copiare soluzioni
dalle razze locali -
mentre con la genomica, da sola,
possiamo aumentare di tre volte
la velocità di selezione,
con questi sistemi messi insieme
possiamo portare tutto in laboratorio,
la selezione che stiamo facendo in campo
la portiamo in laboratorio,
e possiamo aumentare la velocità
da 3X a 30X.
30X vuol dire che in cinque anni
possiamo rifare quello
che è stato fatto in 150 anni.
E questo, voglio dire,
potrebbe da un lato permetterci, anche,
di selezionare per caratteri
molto difficili da selezionare.
Quelli di adattamento all'ambiente.
Quelli di un minore impatto ambientale.
Pensate:
piante che possono
resistere alle malattie;
che possono essere coltivate
su terreni salini;
che possono resistere alla siccità.
Addirittura che possono avere
un'efficienza, soprattutto sintetica,
migliore.
Per cui [possono] catturare
più CO2 dall'atmosfera
e ridurre gli impatti ambientali.
O animali, anche questi
più resistenti alle malattie,
quindi che usano meno farmaci in azienda;
oppure che inquinano di meno:
bovini che producono meno metano,
che è una produzione inutile per loro
e dannosa per l'ambiente.
Come ricercatore, devo dire
che prima di arrivare
a questo tipo di applicazione
vedo una serie di ostacoli tecnici.
Però, guardando indietro,
molti di questi ostacoli
sono stati superati rapidamente,
negli ultimi cinque - dieci anni.
Potremmo essere abbastanza veloci
per poter veramente raggiungere
questo difficile obiettivo
di aumentare le produzioni
e diminuire l'impatto ambientale.
Ma essendo molto, diciamo, hi-tech,
molto potenti, queste tecnologie
è necessario anche che si apra
un dibattito con la società.
Il compito nostro, di ricercatori,
è quello di informare,
di trovare soluzioni
e di dare informazioni
perché questo dibattito si apra,
sia a cuore aperto, senza estremismi.
Per capire come e quando utilizzare
queste tecnologie, e come regolarle.
Nel frattempo, però,
conserviamo la biodiversità
nel settore agro-zootecnico,
perché queste soluzioni
che noi potremmo copiare nel futuro
saranno importantissime per noi
e soprattutto per le generazioni a venire.
Grazie.
(Applausi)